En baie du Mont-Saint-Michel,
au confins des marais blancs et des marais noirs du pays de Dol,
existe un mont entouré de mythes et de légendes,
le Mont-Dol.
Arrivant au pied de ce monolithe de granit,
je décide de faire l’ascension du tertre.
Le rocher est profondément entaillé de nombreuses carrières.
Au 19ème siècle, elles ont livré un trésor,
il va me mener sur la piste des mammouths.
L’histoire débute il y a 600 millions d’années,
une chaine de montagne, la chaine cadomienne se forme.
Vers 540 millions d’années,
du magma remonte dans la croûte terrestre.
Il refroidit en profondeur
et donne naissance au granit du Mont-Dol,
de Chausey,
de Tomblaine,
et du Mont-Saint-Michel.
A partir de 430 millions d’années,
après érosion des reliefs cadomiens,
de nouvelles montagnes se forment.
Vers 320 millions d’années,
du magma s’infiltre dans des failles,
un filon de dolérite cristallise
et coupe littéralement en deux la vieille bulle de granit du Mont-Dol.
En ce petit matin d’hiver,
l’ascension du tertre me coupe les jambes.
Au premier lacet de ce col breton,
je surplombe le versant sud.
Là, s’ouvrent les anciennes carrières de granit
qui dominent le cimetière paroissial.
C’est ici en 1867,
que les premiers ossements sont découverts.
La nouvelle se répand alors comme une trainée de poudre :
« On a trouvé des ossements de baleines au Mont-Dol ! »
En 1872, le doyen de la faculté des sciences de Rennes,
Simon Sirodot, entreprend les premières fouilles.
Elles révèlent un véritable trésor.
En guise de baleines, les ossements sont ceux de mammouths.
Mais aussi de rhinocéros laineux, de rennes, de chevaux, de bœufs,
d’ours, de cerfs, de marmottes et de loups.
Un auteur de l’époque parle même de la « ménagerie du Mont-Dol ».
En plus de ce véritable écosystème,
les fouilles mettent au jour de très nombreux outils de silex taillés.
Datant du paléolithique moyen,
ils sont uniques dans le massif armoricain.
Ces objets me ramènent il y a 110 000 ans,
au tout début de la dernière glaciation.
Le climat se refroidit,
les calottes glaciaires se développent,
le niveau marin baisse.
La manche devient une steppe herbeuse,
fréquentée par de grands herbivores.
Je suis avec les mammouths et les rhinocéros laineux,
des toiles de Mathurin Méheut.
A l’époque,
le Mont-Dol est stratégique pour les chasseurs Néanderthaliens
qui fréquentent la région en quête de gibier.
Au pied du versant sud,
ils construisent leurs huttes à l’abri des vents dominants.
Deux foyers trouvés par Sirodot sur le site attestent qu’ils maitrisent le feu.
Ils ramènent les produits de la chasse au campement pour les préparer.
Les os sont brisés pour en extraire la moelle.
Les restes de mammouths retrouvés sont ceux de jeunes,
certainement plus facile à chasser.
Ensuite le climat se refroidit,
pour atteindre il y a 20 000 ans le maximum glaciaire.
Le niveau marin descend 120 à 130 mètres en dessous du niveau actuel.
Les rivages bretons se situent alors environ 150 kilomètres à l’ouest de Brest.
Hors d’eau, la manche n’est plus qu’une immense plaine
drainée par un énorme fleuve.
Il est la confluence du Pas-de-Calais, de la Seine et de tous les fleuves côtiers.
C’est le paléofleuve Manche.
Il y a 18 000 ans, le réchauffement climatique débute progressivement.
Le niveau marin remonte
pour atteindre – 50 mètres, il y a 10 000 ans.
C’est la fin des mammouths en terre armoricaine.
La suite de l’histoire,
je l’ai devant les yeux au sommet des carrières du tertre.
A la manière des chasseurs néanderthaliens,
je domine les marais noirs,
vestiges du début du comblement de la baie.
Il y a 7500 ans, le Mont-Dol et le Mont-Saint-Michel sont des îles.
En arrière de cordons littoraux,
des marais maritimes avec herbus et tourbières se développent.
Quand la mer remonte successivement il y a environ 6000 et 4000 ans,
elle dépose des tangues aux alentours du Mont-Dol.
Vers l’an 0, le Mont-Dol n’est plus une île.
Il est le tertre sur lequel je suis aujourd’hui,
mais il recèle encore certainement bien des traces
de l’épopée des mammouths.